we start by giving you a quick review of
what happened so it was a
nimzo indian declined if you will a
queen's indian move order with knight f3
rather than of course knight to c3 and
bishop b4 all of the nimzo
and after d5 and g3 we quickly had a
catalan on the board
bishop e7 bishop g2 rekharovka and then
after dc4 queen c2 this was the first
moment right fabi to you b5 not the not
the most popular move here
uh and gave magnus a little bit of pause
before his response yeah the opening was
really fascinating
both from the chess content and also
from
um how the players approached it yeah so
magnus playing the catalan i think shows
that he is going to switch around his
openings with white a lot
um to start with he's not really a
natural catalan player he hasn't played
it too much in the past of course he's
dabbled in everything but it's never
been one of his main openings yep and
also the catalan is difficult to keep
playing again and again because black
has so many decent defenses against it
yep that
uh
you're unlikely to really prove an
advantage in a whole match and jan
played b5 a super sharp line yep um but
he didn't seem perfectly prepared so on
that note
magnus played 95 and robert you were
drawing you were drawing attention to
that point right that despite b5 having
been a move that maybe jan surprised
magnus with
when magnus played 95 suddenly john went
into the think tank he did and that's
not a good sign when you play an
aggressive variation and immediately
after this move 95 which has a clear
threat in the rook on eight you go and
think and spend a lot of time he handled
it well after this point and he started
with the move c6 but it felt like he
wasn't in familiar territory and that's
really a bad thing against magnus
carlsen just for the record in case we
see this game again for all those who
may be still watching us live or
watching this in review on on youtube
queen takes d4 and knight to d5 are two
more popular moves and potentially very
very deep c6 is
not as not as not as common as those two
moves after a4 we get a very traditional
catalan type of compensation with white
having a lot of pressure and black
trying to recover for the next several
moves to develop the queen side and
catch up uh to white's very active
pieces
knight c3 came and then after f6 we we
all stopped here and said look f6 was
the right thing to do right bobby you
you were suggesting it it was played but
we knew it was coming with consequences
for the rest of the game right the e6
pawn and the wheat king
yeah you know i actually just had a
thought a second ago which is that
magnus paused after c6
but he played the move a4 relatively
quickly after some thought
i was wondering if black plays instead
of c6 knight d5
and white plays knight c3
and black plays c6
white can play a4
it will be transposed and transposed so
maybe he was was just trying to get back
into a line which was familiar to him
okay maybe this shows his intention
after an id5 okay um interesting
so okay so anyway um so we come back we
came to a super complicated position
very double edged because you know yep
black has weakened a lot uh on the other
hand of course he's up a pawn
and and jan came up with this
interesting idea that we were all
we were all reacting to because just
queen just doesn't look natural there
and there were tactics coming in a lot
of variations on different diagonals in
hindsight it kind of worked out he had a
defensive setup but robert you just gave
me a quick look your thoughts on that no
the next part of the game was really
interesting because the queen is
stepping on the toes of black's other
pieces yep but it defends everything and
as the game continued here and white
went forward with e4 yep it was a
position that felt very dangerous and
magnus had a choice do i play for d5 or
for e5 we ended up liking his e5 choice
in the next few moves because it opened
up the entire board but just immediately
afterwards he didn't handle it correctly
because he traded on f6
which was great playing good moves and
then this 95 move that was an imprecise
choice yeah right he must have missed
something in yon's response after
bishop takes e5 and knight a6 to c5 yep
because white is the one now with
vulnerable squares as well it's not just
the d6 square it's b3 it's d3 so those
knights are hopping in and when we saw
magnus looking at his scoresheet a bunch
because fabi now that we're looking at
it here putting the whole story together
that we've now watched for the last six
hours right
you were thinking maybe he was still in
prep he was just checking his move order
which means maybe he was thinking about
this position here you you rejoined us
after hoeifan left and said that you
really thought after after the next move
not knight e5 but knight takes f6 was
the key for white to keep an advantage
but the main point being everyone rook
takes allows 95 and this transition is
just very strong for white with the
temple on the rook and the crazy
pressure coming here
and so if you can't take with the rook
and you take with the pawn
now your point was that this position
with the bishop pair
maybe maybe gives him better long-term
chances right to speak for you
i don't think he saw
we were of course speculating on what he
was thinking about at the end because
there are so many moments in this game
it was a very complicated game
where
he could have been thinking about
you know even later on because right
like he was gained a somewhat promising
position later on or even earlier in
opening maybe he was thinking instead of
e takes f6 something um but this is the
moment where i feel like
knight e5 was probably not the right
choice yeah um knight takes a six i'm
not sure if white is really better
because after pawn takes the line you
just said bishop h6
um and rook f7
it's difficult for white to find the
next move
white doesn't have any clear targets uh
e6 is kind of easy to defend with rookie
eight uh the knight on d3 is stopping a
lot of wise development so maybe he
could have thought about 91 here um but
for sure he's he's not worse here and in
the game he was getting worse so right
so in the game as robert just said he
played 95 takes takes and here came
knight a to c5 and suddenly
uh we realized in real time that black's
advantage was growing and that probably
the best practical decision was to go
all in allowing the obvious threat of
knight b3 which forks the rook and the
bishop winning the exchange in order to
to go all in for the compensation on
knight d6 and that's exactly what he did
and that was an amazing night on d6
throughout this game and black
objectively is better here there's no
denying that but it's difficult to get
the pieces fully out you need to play c6
to c5 yeah offer a trade of bishops and
i like what magnus is here with rook to
d1 in case that's gonna happen he wants
his rook attacking the queen on the
d-file but then this was the curious
moment bishop a8 we weren't expecting
that because of that arrow you just had
there the knight can move out of the way
hitting the queen on d7 and
magnus chose not to do that just yet he
played bishop e4 threatening things on
the king side and that's quite scary
because there's all sorts of menacing
moves like queen h5 the h7 square the
sacrifices on g6 so jan plays this c3
move and first bishop a then c3 this
back-to-back move that we felt were not
optimizing the position and then magnus
really had an easy time of it after that
where he was the one sort of pressing so
it just two moves the advantage for
black all of a sudden turned over to
white and it was never in huge danger
but magnus was the one who could try for
more in hindsight you would agree right
bobby this this was the critical moment
the pendulum if you will right if yon
was going to get a different result it
was probably here whether whether we
would argue it was queen e7 instead of
bishop a8 or even after bishop e4 the
concrete line we thought maybe black
should go for just call white's bluff
yeah i think if the moment before he
played bishop bay he had more time
certainly an advantage and a safe one at
that
um
and i i i think queen 7 here was the
right move
but bishop 8 bishop before i think c3
was was really the moment yeah when i
don't i don't understand why this move
was played
it looks like white has a lot of options
after c3
um we even mentioned knight takes b5 as
an option
um
so so why go for this when white has a
lot of attractive or at least decent
looking options well especially why go
for it so quickly again we were talking
about it in real time that he sat down
at the board and you made the point no
matter what you're doing while you're
away from the board you're looking at it
on a monitor you're thinking about it in
your head it's not the same and he sat
down played c3 it was kind of vintage
yawn in the in the vintage yawn that we
that we don't want to see if we're an
upon napaneshi fan right because he does
this so quickly and as robert pointed
out after queen c2 which is very forcing
g6
takes c3 now when the queen takes c5 is
stuck we highlighted how critical it was
to advance this pawn to open the bishop
now you can't do so and as robert said
from here on out
white was in control
yeah because the material advantage at
first was a rook and a pawn for the
knight now white has the same number of
pawns in black but black's pawns are way
worse look at them they're all split a7
c6 e6 upon's best friend is another pawn
those are some lonely pawns bullets and
the way the game continued from here i
mean black did eventually play smooth c5
but it came at the cost of the c5 pawn
yep all these pawns are now targets as
we said the transition while there was
still a lot to talk about in real time
overall
we were already talking about variations
here where when is young going to bail
out when is young going to bail out
right take on d6 and eventually fava you
called it you said that in this position
after
after the the queen c7 when the knight
was undefended it was now time to take
it
yeah
i do wonder a bit if magnus is
regretting playing queen g4
um
and allowing
black to simplify the position rather
than
uh it's it's risky of course to keep
trying to keep the tension because
they're both in time trouble right or
potentially in time trouble and things
can get out of hand for for either one
of them but it feels like white is on
has is the one who has pressure so
maybe
robert suggested a move like rook c1
maybe there were some ways to increase
pressure
um
and of course it would still be in
within the bounds of equality but
without allowing black to easily
um trade off pieces that's a good point
so
rooks you want any other ideas because
this is probably going to be our final
thoughts in the game we know what
happened after this thing's petered out
um well moves which came to mind were
also rook a3 but then black will
possibly just try to play rook d8 and
yeah and there's no rook d3 yeah which
is what you want to play rook d3
protecting the knights was no sacrifice
but rook takes c4 suddenly becomes an
option because too much is happening
down the d file and the rook on d8 is
the one that gets the last lap yep yeah
that's this is why rook c1 was maybe
a chance to play c5 after rook d8 yeah
um because if white gets c5 i think the
pressure can get pretty serious
uh
but black had ways to deal with that too
it's hard to criticize this decision to
play quiche g4 because it's an
objectively fine move
uh
and rooksy one wasn't leading to an
advantage for white objectively but it
would keep more play in the position
right
well as we said queen g4 was played yan
used that as his opportunity to as we
say say enough is enough
head to an end game where you pointed
out white really has nothing better than
to win two for one sacrifices the c pawn
to take care of the ena
but unfortunately for magnus jan is able
to quickly get the queens off the board
and head to a theoretically drawn ending
where we had some fun analyzing and
hopefully highlighting some instructive
stuff for the viewers in chat because
you know we it seems it's trivial for
these guys but there are interesting and
instructive ways these end games can go
wrong however ultimately it was a game
of shuffle puck over there between the
rook and king and game two of the
feeding world chess championship came to
an end peacefully and that was your
coinbase rapid recap of just how it was
chess.com's coverage of the 2021 feed a
world championship is brought to you by
our partners at coinbase whether you're
just thinking about making your first
crypto purchase just wanting to learn a
little bit more about the crypto
industry or if you've been doing this
thing for years and you're an
experienced trader coinbase is the place
to be
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free bitcoin just for signing
up and verifying your account today we
really encourage you to do so go check
them out at coinbase.com
[Music]
you